- Hello, Believe Nation.
I started the Mentor Me series
to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us,
and hopefully, by spending a
little bit more time with them,
some of how they think, their values,
their beliefs, their mindsets,
their attitudes seeps
into us to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going
to learn from Dan Pena
and some of his best motivation.
Mentor me, Dan.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- Best advice I ever got
from Mr. Grazzos, do it.
He didn't say "Just f'ing do it."
He didn't swear.
And the best advice I've
ever given anybody is,
just f'ing do it.
We take too much time procrastinating,
we take too, and because
we're afraid of failure,
and, uh, fear is false
expectations appearing real.
We're worried about
what other people think.
We're trying to fit in.
And I can go through a
whole litany of bullsh'.
Now, it's not bullsh'
'cause it's not true.
Litany of stuff why you are where you are
because you just didn't do it.
You didn't want to make a mistake.
You got a mortgage, you got two ex-wives,
you got a 15-year-old
daughter who's pregnant,
I can go, your dad's got Alzheimer's,
your mother's got emphysema
spitting up blood.
I can go on, and on, and on, and on!
But the bottom f'ing line is,
if 15 years ago you had just done it,
10 years ago if you'd just f'ing done it,
five years ago if you'd
just f'ing done it,
six months ago if you'd
you probably wouldn't be in
the position you're in now.
So I'm saying, no matter what your age is,
it's still time to just
f'ing go out and do it.
Just go out and f'ing do it.
Most of you lack the skills
to sell your vision with clarity.
Because you don't practice,
and the travesty really is,
is because you don't believe enough in it.
You just don't.
And if what you're trying
to finance isn't your dream,
isn't your vision,
I mean, the banker or the
person on the other side
of the table sees through it clearly.
They know just absolutely, definitively.
Because at the end of the day,
they want to feel down,
deep inside, warm and fuzzy
that this person or this person
will do whatever it takes
to pay me back the money.
And if you don't believe
with all your heart,
then you're not going to,
you know, go that extra mile.
That's what they want to believe,
and most of you don't believe passionately
in what you're doing.
And that's why it's
very easy for me to say
you got to turn the damn
key, just walk away.
And look for something that you
can passionately believe in.
Is that so difficult?
I'm 15 pounds overweight.
My doctor said, and he said, you know,
if you wanted be in perfect health,
which everything else is
perfect, my health, I'm well,
you should lose 15 pounds.
And I said, "I'd have to give
up three or four martinis
"and a bottle of wine every night.
"I'm not willing to do that."
I know what it takes, and
I know what I'd have to do.
I used to run marathons.
I ran the Boston Marathon,
and I know what it took to train,
and, I'm not, you know, I
don't run like that anymore.
I StairMaster, but I mean, I,
we all know how to lose weight,
we all know how to get physically fit,
we all know how to build our businesses!
I can go to the Yellow Pages today
and pick out any business
that's in this room,
and I could find somebody
that's beating your brains out.
I don't care what you do.
And, as some of you have heard me say,
but I'm going to say it
again 'cause it's important,
for this example, again,
we're all going to have 100 IQ.
For some of you, I'm giving you some,
for some I'm taking away some.
We all know nobody can
have 10 times our IQ.
Well then why the hell do
people make 10 times more
than we do, 1000 times more than we do?
Why?
Because they think and
dream bigger than we do.
High performance people
have high expectations,
not average expectations.
- [Moderator] Do you think
anyone in this room could go
and make hundreds of millions
of dollars using your system?
- It is simple.
Can everybody in this room do it?
No, because everybody in
this room's not willing
to make the sacrifices.
I don't know how to do
a four hour work week,
which came up a little earlier.
I don't know, and I know Ferriss.
And if you believe the
four hour work week,
I've got a bridge to sell you in New York.
(audience laughs)
I mean, one of the comments
from the seminar that just ended
from the 1820 Kids, all of
which were about half my age,
we had a couple of old gits in their 40s,
but most of them were less than 30.
They commented at breakfast the last day,
which was Saturday or Sunday,
they said, "How can he
still be so fired up,
"running on 200% of all the cylinders
"when he's been on his feet 15 hours a day
"for six, seven, eight
days, and we've been sitting
"on our arses, uh, and
we're tired and he's not?"
You know why?
Because I, and if you don't find something
that you love what you do, don't bother,
because if you don't have a passion
for what you do and you love, it gets old.
I say this stretching a little.
It's like a significant other
that you've been around too much.
You know what I mean?
Everybody in this room can
relate to that, I think.
Okay, well, if you're not passionate
about what you do in life, it gets old,
and then it becomes work, and
as soon as it becomes work,
you're finished.
The reason why I'm fired
up at the end of a six,
seven day week of 15, 18 hours a day,
is because I'm passionate
about pulling you sorry asses
across the goal line.
'Cause that's my goal in life now,
to pull as many of the sorry,
individuals on the planet
across the goal line
as I can before they put dirt on me.
But does that look like your group?
No, it doesn't look like your group.
I mean, in no way, shape, manner or form.
You know, maybe if we had a bunch
of bunny rabbits running there.
Or um, it's unbelievable, but,
again, you are who you
hang around with, you know?
And as Oprah Winfrey says,
which I talk about a lot,
is that you want people with a like mind,
and that are better than
you, smarter than you,
more intelligent than
you to get on your butts.
Don't be so concerned about
what you're going to do
with those people, but
you want to, you know,
the joint brain is, you know,
there's nothing the joint brain,
collective brain or brains can't overcome.
And I give the example of the atomic bomb,
Manhattan Project, and
they were put together
and they were told we need,
uh, we need to develop
a weapon of mass destruction,
which they didn't call it
that back in those days,
in the middle 40s, to end
the war in the Pacific.
And they did.
They didn't know if it
was implode or explode,
but they did.
But if your team doesn't look
like that, then you should,
I won't say you should
give serious thought,
you should just f'ing change.
If you are not experiencing anxiety,
if your problems are not replaced
as soon as you solve one with a bigger one
that's geometrically bigger,
then you're not growing.
I hate to hear people tell me,
"My business is running
smoothly, everything's great."
Well then, he might as well blow,
or she might as well
blow their brains out,
because they sure as hell aren't growing.
What my deal is all about
is growing geometrically,
quantumly, and just remember
that, and keep an open mind.
Because I have been there and done that,
there's no question about that.
Another thing, and I said this yesterday,
just because you haven't done it,
just because you've never
been around somebody
that hasn't done it, and just because
you've never heard of it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist,
'cause absence of evidence is
not evidence of their absence.
I'm going to say some things
that are real foreign to you,
some things that you been
taught by your parents,
your grandparents, in school,
and basically all that is crap.
Now, I'm not talking about moral issues
and things like that, or religion.
I don't get into that.
I was raised a Roman Catholic.
I'm still a Roman Catholic and
my wife's a convert Catholic
if that gives you any idea about
where I stand on religion.
But I'd be glad to debate
any of that during the break.
So just keep an open mind.
The high performance
people that I will continue
to allude to all day long,
live in a different world than you.
They came from the same world as you did,
but they live in a different
world, they think differently.
Unless we've built the right foundation,
I mean, the house will be wobbly,
and it'll be, you know, we got
to build the right foundation.
And, for the most part,
most people in this room
and most people listening
on YouTube have to come
to the realization, as sad as
it is, that you have pissed,
you have urinated, heretofore
up until this morning,
your entire life down a f'ing sh'hole.
Very simple.
That's it.
If you want to create massive wealth,
if you just want to be
a happy slappy housewife
from f'ing Dundee,
or a happy slappy bimbo from f' Toronto,
or a happy slappy guy who goes
to the Little League games
in Mesa, Arizona, then that's okay.
But if you want to
create some f'ing money,
and money's not everything,
but if you don't think
money can buy happiness,
you don't know where to f'ing shop.
You can get money and
then go save the world.
You can get money and save
the forests in Brazil.
You make money and go save global warming,
which I don't believe in.
I mean, save the kids in
Africa and all that shit.
But without money, you
can't save a f'ing thing.
Don't you understand?
Don't the f'ing idiots on
YouTube understand that?
Until you make some shekels,
until you make some f'ing coin,
you can't help anybody.
Because if love got the job done,
you wouldn't all be f'ed up.
Matthew and I were discussing
some of the things, um,
about why you discounted,
on a subconscious level,
some of the things that have happened,
because absence of evidence
is not evidence of absence,
and he said something very profound.
For an Australian, this
is heavy duty sh't.
But he said, "I decided to do it.
"Even though it was stupid,
I decided to do it."
Stupid meaning follow the process
to an intellectually bright
guy who's an engineer.
And see, he won't.
You, so you'll figure out a better way.
And he followed the
stupid process that works
and has been working for 45 years.
20 some years before, when I was doing it,
and 22 years since I've been coaching.
And he called it, he wasn't
trying to be insulting
or anything, he says, "I
just decided to follow it."
You know, how did you say it?
- [Man] Instead of trying to be smart,
I was just trying to be stupid,
shut that part off of
my brain and just do it.
- And what happens?
He did it.
And that's why,
it's hard for the YouTubers
and all the other,
because you can't dumb,
you know, dumb down.
You will not believe that it's easy.
You know, you won't.
But he put it very succinctly.
He just dumbed down, and shut
off that part of his brain,
and just followed the steps.
You don't need f'ing case studies.
You have a, you have a f'ing template,
you have a m'ing script that
a f'ing monkey can read.
That Alex wants a f'ing case study
because he wants to
know the sh't behind it,
'cause he's stupid,
and that's why he's f'ing poor.
You don't need any m'ing case studies.
How many f'ing times do I have to say?
You have the f'ing script!
I said, don't change a
f'ing word on the script!
Not a comma!
If it's got misspelled f'ing words,
send it out misspelled!
The last thing you f'ing
need is a f'ing case study!
This is why you're f'ing poor!
This is why the c' watching this
on YouTube are so f'ing poor!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or to your business?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Surge Wisdom.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making that review
on your YouTube channel.
I'm glad you enjoyed the book,
and I really, really
appreciate your support.
(cheery ukulele music)
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.